you've had some pretty major adventures
Luke Hobbs ever since going after the
Toronto crew in Fast Five your life has
been wild then you teamed up with them a
few times to get the real bad guys and
don't forget about Shaw he might have
tried to end your life more than once
but you two worked well together in
Hobbes and Shaw so where are you these
days
fast and furious fans were disappointed
to find out that Dwayne Johnson will not
be in Fast and Furious 9 is it just a
scheduling conflicts or does it have to
do with a certain co-star keep watching
to find out why were you I'd use the
time make peace with whatever demons you
got left
Dwayne Johnson already had a huge fan
base when he joined the fast saga in
2011 he was in Fast Five he was a
government agent who wanted to take down
Toretto's crew because he thought they
were behind the demise of DEA agents but
after his team meets their untimely end
he joins up with Toretto to bring down
Reyes he was back in Fast & Furious 6 to
ask Toretto for help bringing down Owen
Shaw in Furious 7 Hobbs
meets Deckard Shaw and the two become
enemies he saves the world alongside
Toretto in the fate of the Furious by
this time Luke Hobbs is a crucial part
of the franchise we thought that he
retired to spend time with his daughter
but then he's called back into action he
teams up with Deckard Shaw in 2019 s
Hobbs and Shaw fans now think of Luke
Hobbs as part of the saga he's just as
popular as Vin Diesel's character
Toretto these two work well together as
characters but the real-life story isn't
quite as smooth
I'll see you soon Toretto in fate of the
Furious the drama and danger were amped
up to a whole new level this movie was
about a lot more than stolen cars and
drug wars Hobbs gets thrown into prison
and mysteriously released there's an EMP
device in the hands of a cyber terrorist
who goes by the name of cypher he has to
help Dom Toretto track down this bad guy
it's intense and the whole world is at
stake but the drama behind the scenes
was even more intense Dwayne took to
social media to say that he was angry at
someone in the cast he insulted this
person's professionalism and called him
some choice words it was soon confirmed
that this person was Vin Diesel who
plays dog Toretto apparently Dwayne was
so angry that he said a lot of his
character's anger wasn't just acting he
was just that mad on set he tried to
smooth things over by saying that all
families had philosophical differences
but the feud did not end there you're
going down Toretto
I'm right here
a few days later Vin Diesel
posts on social media saying that he
would soon tell his side of the story
but he never did
then filming wrapped Dwayne shared a
heartfelt thank you post on Instagram he
thanked everyone involved in the
production of the eighth film he
mentioned a lot of the most important
people by name but he left out Vin
Diesel Vin Diesel is the star of the
franchise he was to Wayans counterpart
for the whole movie he's also one of the
producers for the franchise everyone
noticed that he was left out of the post
Michelle Rodriguez their co-star
confirmed to the feud she said that she
and the others knew to stay out of their
way
many people speculated that her words
meant things turned physical between the
rock and VIN by the time the movie was
released things settled down VIN said
that things might have been blown out of
proportion
he said he and Dwayne are actually close
and his kids call the rock uncle Dwayne
then he said that they're both alphas so
they're bound to butt heads in 2019 the
next movie in the Fast saga was released
Fast and Furious presents Hobson's Shah
was a box-office success but this movie
isn't part of Dom Toretto storyline it's
a complete spin off Dwayne Johnson is
pulled out of his retirement to save the
world again he's teamed up with Deckard
Shaw of the rogue British intelligence
officer that he put in prison they have
to work together to find a super virus
that can eradicate all of humanity it's
a great action movie with the buddy-cop
vibe
even without Toretto the movie felt true
to the franchise Jason Statham reprised
his role as Shaw but Vin Diesel wasn't
just missing from the cast
he had teased that fast and furious
spin-offs were in the works before Hobbs
and Shaw was announced VIN had been a
producer of every movie in the franchise
since the sequel too fast too furious
but he was not a producer on Hobbs and
Shaw Johnson and Jason were however
could this be the part of the
philosophical differences that led to
their feud
not everyone from The Fast and Furious
franchise was happy about Hobson Shaw
Vin Diesel never publicly spoke about it
and it seems like their feud is somewhat
settled but Tyrese Gibson who plays
Roman Pearce had some thoughts when the
vin and Dwayne Feud made news Tyrese
made it clear he was not involved he
said he had no problems with Dwayne and
would never have any problems that
wasn't the case
he called his co-star out for making the
franchise all about Dwayne was he just
bitter about Dwayne getting a solo
spin-off or was there more to it he
posted that the movie would probably be
another Baywatch implying that it would
flop but it topped the box office even
with that Tyrese called the rock out for
having the lowest opening of the
franchise he said Dwayne tried to break
up the family that social media post has
the since been deleted Tyrese says that
he regrets his public outburst but he
has not apologized for what he said
about Dwayne Tyrese is in Fast 9 even
though Dwayne isn't me
Vinh and dwayne have made peace over
their feud at least publicly no one
knows exactly what their fight was about
and no one knows if they're really still
friends or if they just made peace for
the sake of the franchise VIN has said
that Dwayne only has one VIN in his life
he told USA Today that he is like
Dwayne's big brother and that he's
always rooting for him in the summer of
2019 Finn worked even harder to make
peace he uploaded an Instagram post
congratulating Dwayne for the success of
Hobbs and Shaw he then went on to
congratulate the rock for his wedding
Dwayne posted his own video in response
he thanked Ben for his very classy post
on event brother Ben for your support I
saw your post but bands thought the
whole exchange sounded very formal and
forced our things really okay between
these two or is this all a publicity
stunt to ensure the success of Fast and
Furious 9 and will Dewayne ever reappear
in the past saga keep watching to find
out until next time till next time
Dwayne Johnson isn't going to be in fast
and furious 9 Jason Statham is also
missing out on this next movie we guess
Hobbs and Shaw have other things to do
here's what we do know Vin Diesel is
back and so is Charlize Theron as cypher
John Cena is joining the family - Han is
back as well we thought that he met his
end in a fiery car crash we can't wait
to see how that plays out Justin Lin is
returning as the director for the movie
he directed five of the film's from
Tokyo Drift - to Fast & Furious 6 we
know it should be good with Justin at
the helm and there will be tons of hot
new cars and it takes place then
destinations all over the world
fast and furious 9 is set to premiere on
May 22nd 2020 please tell me that's not
a Pontiac Fiero strap through a rocket
engine impressive I know No
john cena is joining the cast of fast
and furious 9
he plays dom Toretto's estranged to
brother Jakob so we're up against a
master thief
fasten high-performance driver John has
a lot in common with Dwayne Johnson they
both got their start as wrestlers in the
WWE and they both turned to acting
they're both great in action movies and
comedies but they actually have some be
for real life when the rock left
wrestling John publicly criticized him
for forgetting his roots John said that
Dwayne had loved wrestling but wouldn't
ever come back for a reunion show of
course John later left WWE to act too he
sensed apologize for his comments
because he didn't understand the demands
of being an actor all reports say that
the two are really close these days but
with John Cena Tyrese Gibson and Vin
Diesel in one movie that's a lot of
drama
what's even more bizarre is that they've
all got beef with Dwayne the rock and I
are most known for our tremendous in WWE
feud officially Dwayne Johnson has said
that he isn't in Fast 9 because of
scheduling conflicts and that certainly
could be the case Dwayne has become one
of the most popular stars in Hollywood
according to IMDB he has 8 movies set to
come out as of 2020 Disney's Jungle
Cruise comes out later this year
he's also filming red notice and there
are 6 more projects that have either
been announced or are currently in
pre-production one of those is a TV
series called young rock which is about
his early life he will also be starring
in the king he plays a Hawaiian king who
wants to reunite the islands but by all
accounts he loves the fog ax he's a busy
man but is that enough to keep him from
reprising his role as Hobbs hey thanks
for being my sidekick through this whole
thing brother
you were great fast 10 fast and furious
10 is definitely happening it's set to
premiere in the spring of 2021 that's
not that far off there's a good chance
that it will be the final installment in
the Fast Saga
it will be the tenth movie about
Toretto's group it will also be 20 years
since the franchise began we don't know
yet whether there will be more spin-off
films like Hobbes and Shaw so we'll do
an Johnson comeback for fast 10 it's
possible he has hinted that he will be
back he says
Hobbs and Toretto have some unfinished
business he also hinted that Shah would
be back too we have to say that it would
be epic to see a showdown between John
Cena and Dewayne who wouldn't love a WWE
reunion on the big screen if he is
coming back for the tenth movie he's
gotta have room in his schedule we can't
wait to see what happens in the ninth
and tenth installments who's your
favorite fast and furious character let
us know in the comments tomorrow
I'll see you soon thanks for watching
the things give this video a thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe see you
next time
you